Donald Trump tells Glenn Beck you have
no choice he will absolutely lock people
up if returned to the White House he
didn't say it with much enthusiasm but
uh here's the clip for all of you
and in you know uh lock her up and then
when you became president you said we
don't do that in America that's just not
the right thing to do that's what
they're doing do you regret not locking
her up and if you're president again
will you lock people up
well I'll give you an example uh the
answer is you have no choice because
they're doing a test I always had such
great respect for the Office of the
President the presidency and but the
Office of the President and I never hit
Biden as hard as I could have
and then I heard he was trying to indict
me and it was him that was doing it you
know I don't think he's sharp enough to
think about much but he was there and he
was probably the one Glenn Beck's life
he was you know hard to believe that he
even thinks about that because he's he's
gone but then I said well they're
actually trying to indict me because
every one of these indictments is him
including brag you know brag put his he
put his time so he got it he says he's
going to lock people up what I want to
add to this is Rachel Maddow recently
said that Donald Trump is only running
because he wants to solve his legal
problems that's actually Joe Biden right
and now that Joe Biden is president he's
probably saying all I can do is either
win re-election or lock Trump up but if
Trump wins I'm going down and of course
you have to accuse your opponents of
doing what you in fact are doing so
Rachel Maddow comes out blames Trump
says he wants to be president for life I
guess the question is one do you really
think Trump will do this and then after
we answer that my question for you
Joshua is uh are you also going to lock
people up uh yeah I I definitely want to
investigate the coveted regime and about
you a fouchy safer uh any gov any
Governor yes because yes you know I feel
like saying just the covid regime does
it go far enough yes yes
there's definitely there's definitely
people that need to be locked don't let
them turn you to the dark side yes uh no
they won't um no the light is trying to
to save there is criminals there is
nothing Divine fire there is nothing
illiberal about enforcing the law
no because if it's if it's if you have a
liberal Society especially a society
like ours that protects the people
protects rights your laws should not be
violating people's rights not without
due process so if you've got someone
that has has been using the government
the federal government to enrich their
own family there's nothing immoral about
it about enforcing like enforcing the
law or investigating it this earlier
today I I've tweeted there's currently a
member of an amount of circumstantial
evidence Joe Biden has engaged in pay
for influence in Ukraine via his son the
president of the United States Donald
Trump was impeached by the Democrats for
investigating this like that's actually
what happened like there is no reason
why we shouldn't investigate the entire
Biden Administration the whole
administration his family like all of
his business associations they know it
who's gonna who's gonna force that
investigation though well I mean that's
that I'm saying that that would be if
Trump were to be here's the big question
do you actually think Trump is going to
do anything
uh no it's not I don't think it's a
matter of whether Trump will want to I
think it's a matter of whether Trump
will be able to successfully execute
because it's a matter of can he find
people in government that are or that
could fulfill the roles that are
competent that will be able to get into
positions in the bureaucracy and
actually process investigate and
prosecute will they be able because you
know that they're going to be people in
FBI and CIA and stuff like that that are
going to be doing all they can to hide
stuff so it's a matter of will he be
able to get people that are effective
will he want to I think he'll want to
will he execute
who knows this is a
we we just heard that Enrique tario's
sentencing was delayed because the judge
fell ill it was an emergency and they're
trying to lock up Enrique and other
members of The Proud boys for 33 years
ridiculous Donald Trump gets elected
these men are pardoned
there there should be I I believe Trump
pardons them everybody everybody that
like everybody on January 6th in my like
even the people that were getting into
fights with cops they've already done
their time they've already done enough
time now consider let him go
if we are talking about
Civil War everybody drink oh here we go
yeah uh you have these individuals being
accused and and convicted of seditious
conspiracy quite literally they were
accused of a plot to overthrow the
United States in support of Donald Trump
the argument being brought forward by
the Democrats is that Trump was their
leader who actually wanted them and
encouraged them to do this
if Trump gets elected
how will the view of the left not be
Donald Trump succeeded in overthrowing
the United States government that will
be the narrative it will be shoved
Down's people's throat and every single
like you know
wine mom is going to buy it so how could
any of these liberals or leftists argue
we are not in a civil war if they
believe that proud boys were engaged in
a seditious conspiracy at the direction
of Donald Trump to overthrow the United
States and Donald Trump still has a path
to gain power in fact they believe he
currently is likely to win
I think that will be the narrative I
mean there's there's no doubt about it
that's going to be the narrative
everyone runs with it especially if he
wins do do you honestly think that he
will uh pardon Enrique though yes you do
I I I'm not saying it's 100 sure but I
think um we've already got I'm not your
buddy guy in the Super Chat saying
Robert Barnes for A.G I'm I'm wondering
if
Trump plays the tepid role and just wins
and goes ah we gotta slow down blah blah
or does Trump go in and say at this
point I am done and then he Robert
Barnes he starts bringing in Die Hard
Trump supporters to do these jobs who
will do without question because he did
not do that the first time he went to
his donors he went to the establishment
and said you know who do you think would
be good let's play ball and then they
tried to destroy him and he walked he He
Walked the Line there there you've
you've got these false charges and
accusations of being a Russian spy
you've got the you know he he tries to
dig into the Ukraine Scandal and they
impeach him over it and what does he do
nothing right so I'm not entirely
convinced but I do think there's a
possibility that if Trump is elected
it's revenge and then you'll see Maga
personalities I mean look look at
Jeffrey Clark
acting Assistant Attorney General and
they've criminally indicted him if Trump
brings that guy back I imagine he's
gonna be like I can't imagine because
we've had Jeffrey Clark here I can't
imagine this kind of guy who's going to
be like I want revenge no he's going to
be the guy who says yo these people are
corrupt and if we're going to save this
country they must be criminally charged
right Joshua I I have a question how
many and what departments would you
abolish
we don't have net levels there's not
enough there's not enough time on the
show no no it's easier to ask which
department
thank you I appreciate that which ones
would you leave no I can't even think of
any right now I know that we're going
after the ATF first I I believe 100 and
Vivek talked a lot about this that you
can't actually the president doesn't
actually have the power to go and
abolish some of these things like on his
own no but you you The Vape mentioned
like Mass layoffs it's not about layoffs
it's about
organizational RFI as well where you can
transfer right and stuff like that it's
like when you when you when you're a
boss at a company and you know you can't
fire someone so you put them in the
janitor's class I hope they quit my goal
is to get rid of everybody at the ATF
and then uh level level the ATF building
and turn it into a dog park I'd auction
off all the uh leftover ATF equipment no
no no no no no no I I I absolutely I can
pay uh that we can pay reparations to
people who had to unconstitutionally buy
NFA tax stamps I am I am uh I am
offended by this notion I reject this
notion the ATF building should be turned
into large gun super malls that would be
good too yes that's that's a we can do
we can do both with the different
buildings but I think in honor of all
the dogs murdered you know I know so
much
I have I have a friendly relationship
with the people at Brownells and I
wonder if they want a new location in
Washington DC yeah oh there you go
apparently they're up there too
absolutely no I I can't think of many I
can't think of an agency that I'd keep
keep right now yeah I'm trying I'm like
I had a really good conversation with
Austin Peterson
I I had a good conversation about the
CIA but maybe the Department of
Transportation like well Department of
energy is the one I'm thinking of cars
cars yeah but if we're trying to manage
Interstate Rail and and freight and
stuff it it might might make sense I
mean I'm not saying it does to have some
kind of organizing body for so it's
easier for California to adjudicate you
know
between other states if like Wyoming has
got an issue and then I guess the courts
could handle that well I don't think I
know the IRS is gone right away oh yeah
the first one out the door and I would
like to abolish the income tax entirely
that includes the state tax payroll tax
and capital gains tax how do people not
vote for this and then and then I want
to Institute what's user fees which is
what the federal government always
should have been user fees if you use if
listen if you're an American paying the
federal government you don't need
anything from the federal government
there's no reason you should be paying
the federal government period plain and
stuff so like what if you want to drive
on an interstate highways toll so if
there yeah if there's a Fed yeah maybe
maybe we go to some kind of toll system
too but there's already a lot of toll
booths for a lot of different
interstates around the country but user
fees and and it would be a while like
there's people forget that there is
there the tax there's a federal tax in
every gallon of gas that is sold and the
reason that there is a federal tax the
what sold people on it was tax is going
to be used to pay for the highways so
you've got the federal government taxing
every gallon of gas they have plenty of
money
that's the problem is that all these
bills reports with are Port packed with
pork and and they're paying for pet
projects I mean it comes out of Social
Security it comes out of the gas tax it
comes out but the point is we don't need
to have an income tax for a lot of the
things that people think we need the
income tax for and also we are on we are
our government works with a modern
monetary policy basic Theory so there
they don't really care about collecting
taxes to pay for anything if they want
something they print the money to pay to
make it and then they just collect taxes
to reduce inflation just really quickly
to add your point and uh I don't know
how many people watching know this but
prior to the National Tax Act and even
the 16th Amendment there was uh there
there was still a government that
operated before they stole it that's not
true straight from your paycheck yeah
absolutely and this is a story they tell
kids it's scary you know if you want
National Defense or whatever I mean
listen any patriotic American that likes
their National Defense System if you
told them we're not going to take your
payroll taxes anymore but would you be
willing to voluntarily crowdfund our
national military with 10 bucks a month
I guarantee there's a millions of people
are going to pay for that everything I
got an idea we talked about this with a
fake um if you want to vote you have to
sign up for the draft
that's uh there's a lot of theories like
that sign up for the draft there's also
uh if you want to vote you should be a
property owner a landowner I don't know
if you've heard that one floating around
yeah the the I don't agree with that
because uh
we're we're in an era of renting which
didn't exist back in the day it made
sense back in the day it's like hey if
you live here you can vote on what we're
doing but if you don't live here why are
you voting on what we're doing you don't
live here now it's like well I do live
here I rent a room upstairs I'm an
anti-draft so I don't think that I'm an
inscription so let me ask you though if
uh let's say that the the uh
all these apartments are about you get
elected president you walk in you you
start signing executive executive orders
so fast your your right arm is just
massive and we're going to yeah and
you've signed like 10 000 documents
you're drenched in sweat the rest of
your body is disheveled and falling
apart like Joe Joe Biden to the normal
after all of that
a Utopia a Libertarian Utopia exists and
then China invades California with a
massive force of 300 000 troops and they
start just gunning down and massacring
people and at that point do you say we
need a draft we need to get people to
come and fight no so so I wouldn't
listen if I got if you people were wild
enough to actually put me in the White
House okay let's say that first okay as
a Libertarian if if you guys are crazy
enough to come in the white house right
now I appreciate it I'm gonna do all the
work I possibly can to make sure that
people have more freedoms every day I'm
not in any place to immediately cut the
military that's just crazy bringing
troops home stopping Wars abroad closing
down some bases that we don't need
around the world I think that's an
important step and then a more
aggressive Mental Health Care policy for
our vets that are coming home from broad
that are need to reintegrate in with
their wives and families and stuff
because we haven't taken care of our
veterans in this country at all at all I
am a veteran
um but it's not like I'm going to come
in on day one and be like that's it all
military Terry's done you're all going
home I'm just saying in the hypothetical
scenario you're talking about an
anarchist Society no I'm just saying in
the hypothetical hypothetical scenario
that the United States is directly
invaded and we have multiple forces
storming our beaches and taking over our
cities you still oppose conscription uh
yes I would I would oppose conscription
and in fact I think that I think that
our uh you know our citizens are going
to do what the military would do on
their own for their own home and they'd
volunteer I think I think they're going
to take up arms I mean we have more guns
here in the United States that's why no
one's ever really invaded the United
States there's more guns here yeah but
also in the United States is real damn
big to invade yeah you look at you look
at like crossing the mountains would be
harder than Afghanistan for sure yeah I
mean it's it's just like like I was
saying earlier like getting through the
mountain ranges in the west coast like
people talk about oh well you know China
invading blah blah the Rockies will shut
down in advance like nothing Appalachia
yeah and yeah Appalachia would too I
mean like the U.S has has could you
imagine
Great Lakes too in Russia or China
invading and they're trying to move
Westward through Appalachia and there's
a bunch of they're done right-wing nut
jobs with the parrot M82 is up on a
mountain they're taking them off one by
one I don't know if you would need to
Institute a draft to defend but if if
there's no military command overseeing
the logistics then it would just be
disparate factions I don't think I don't
think we're gonna get really the best
option if you're trying to defend I will
that's exactly what the Taliban yeah
they don't have a centralized thing
Taliban got whipped around for two
decades the town they took over in two
seconds you're not taught okay so like
you're not talking about individual
engagements individual engagements the
Taliban lose individual engagements the
Vietnamese lost but because of the
policy goal that the government's had
they were unattainable so even the
individual battles and engagements they
lose they're never going to achieve the
policy goals which is why rifles and a
determined enemy will always all always
beat an invading Army and I will say to
look up the Afghanistan papers if you
haven't I'm sure your crowd always knows
about that but the government knew knew
that that was an unwanted war in
Afghanistan 100 even at the very
beginning but they had to do to defend
was the the Taliban was living in caves
and the Vietnamese were living
underground literally in Tunnels for 10
years
[Music]
what's the option it's our background
the option is you draft your neighbors
and you get organized with the military
it's an invasion yeah
defensive War I mean what that's what
the draft people are going to fight it
anyways here if they invade and they
take a beachhead and they take land
they're all the federal government is
already strapped if if if they if a a
foreign government a foreign military
actually manages to establish a
beachhead and and have the beginning of
an infrastructure to take mainland
United States the amount like the
government has to be in shambles by then
anyways for that to even become I I
disagree you don't think the federal
government Southern no well that's not
that's not that's fine I'm talking about
Landing crafts
I'm saying the federal government is
incapable of dealing with Perhaps it is
by Design but I I I don't think
I think people overestimate the the the
capabilities of the United States I I
absolutely do they there are people who
have been saying over and over again for
years the federal government won't allow
this they won't allow that it's like how
many how many federal law enforcement
officers and and how many people are you
think are in the military
the military is somewhere around I'll
tell you this if I was a tyrant and I
was running this country as a tyrant and
I wanted to weaken this country to make
it submit one of the things I would do
is I would send all of my troops to over
200 bases around the country with the
world within the world yeah 200 bases
around the world and make it very easy
to invade this country do you think if
we sort of bring our troops home you'd
be as worried about
us having a war here in the United
States I'd be less worried if our troops
were at home yes absolutely 100 yeah so
bring them home is is the important and
good and righteous thing but then there
is the argument of staging offensive
operations to prevent an attack the
United States I just I just want to
stress I really love the idea of
imagining what would it be like if a
foreign Invader came to Appalachia I do
it all the time it's so fun it's so fun
to imagine because when you go up to
like there's various mountains over here
and we know all the people live in these
mountains and they are they they
lovingly call themselves right-wing nut
jobs and then they have like guns
everywhere and I'm just saying there'll
be a guy up on a mountain with his
Barrett and he's going to be alike just
waiting it's like do you want to no
one's coming he's like I want to be here
in case they do I think the age of
ground invasion is kind of not really
over but like World War II they had to
drop nukes on Japan because they knew a
ground invasion of the of the island
would have been a Million Dead Americans
like you can't fight in entrenched Force
it'd be insane for them to send ground
invasion in the United
so here's the first thing you get you'd
get cyber attacks which would cut off
your infrastructure you'd lose you'd
lose gasoline oil electricity goes out
then you'll get strategic drone strikes
after the infrastructure is Just Whipped
to shreds then you get the ground forces
coming in to secure the the territory
you cannot occupy a street corner with a
drone so after they decimate any kind of
infrastructure I mean really people need
to consider what it means if our oil uh
pipelines get shut down that's another
thing people don't realize there's only
a handful of places that actually refine
oil so like Jersey right outside of New
York City uh new or New Orleans and I
believe in La those are the three places
that you can import oil into the U.S and
if I understand correctly I could be
wrong but if I understand correctly
that's it you take those you take out
those cities or those refineries and the
U.S oil production I believe comes to
comes close to a standstill is
significantly hurt Rachel Maddow had
that famous line where she's like Russia
could shut up of your electricity in the
winter with a Cyber attack it's like
well what they probably do is they'd
probably just uh destroy the North
Dakota Frack Fields yeah large amounts
of energy produced in these areas fossil
fuels they'd shut that down they'd have
to come through Canada to get there no
they wouldn't they'd go on their
computer in Russia and type a few lines
of code and hit enter and it goes down
now that is whether or not you believe
that uh we have defensive capabilities
in our infrastructure ten years ago we
did not we were running industrial
Control Systems from the 70s and of
course I guess the prevailing Theory or
one of them was that every major world
power had already gained a death grip on
the Cyber infrastructure of every other
country and at any minute mutually sure
destruction at that point was we press
enter and your electricity goes out and
it's not coming back and then the
response was yeah we'll do the same to
you because we have off Network machines
that are capable of shutting you down
mutually assured destruction everyone
thinks is nukes flying at this point
it's a guy pressing enter and look at
look at stuxnet remember that yeah that
was 10 years ago Iranian amazing they
were like release the virus and let it
go into the wild and eventually find its
way to the Iranian centrifuges and blow
them up they don't even need to do
anything on U.S soil whether they're
Cyber attack or Invasion canals the Suez
and Panama we're already seeing all the
packs of the Panama backup imagine like
we'll rely on all of our products all of
our lives are through China so what if
they stop all Transportation coming from
that way you know so I'm not even
worried about the U.S people you know
it's a really good argument for making
more things in America by the way
absolutely people really don't
understand and haven't taken a
consideration what would happen during a
war and we have not even ever scratched
the surface on what would happen you
know we were talking about Civil War the
other night
and uh I forgot who the guest was they
said peaceful divorce which I said is
absolutely impossible impossible but
peaceful divorce it's like a peaceful
impossible because of resource War
because North Dakota is producing energy
because uh California is reliant on the
Colorado River it flows through Nevada
Nevada could shut it down Arizona could
shut it down Colorado could shut it down
and then everyone Downstream is pulling
out guns a lot of Chinese were shutting
down a river that was going into uh
India that was a big that's a great
retention spot between the two countries
National divorce supporter I I uh I I
also agree with you I don't think that
it would be completely peaceful but who
is going to be the unpeaceful one in
that situation but I mean who China and
international divorce but what do you
mean who like the federal government
will tell the states they can't leave
right but it's not about States it's not
about States leaving
the the idea that Civil War is is I said
it's 50 billion times is going to follow
the track of 1861 is an absurd notion
like one time this thing happened and
now everyone's like that's how all Civil
Wars will always be no more likely what
will happen is uh Arizona will say we
need to build a a reservoir because of
the drought impacts we've been having so
we're going to begin construction Nevada
then says if you do this you will cut
off our water supply for 16 months and
we will die and they'll say if we don't
do this we will die and then Nevada says
you are not cutting our water off and
then Arizona says Try Us
there you go the question is whether or
not the federal government can be
stretched so thin people under people
overestimate the power of the U.S uh of
U.S federal law enforcement and of the
military if we are engaged in Conflict
uh on a border or internationally and we
and we actively are with U.S trips being
sent to Europe and confidence is lost in
the federal government for a variety of
reasons all that needs to happen is not
that a state secedes but that estate has
a problem that cannot be adjudicated
properly and there is no federal law
enforcement to come and prevent violence
from erupting I don't know if that can
happen or when it could happen or
whatever I'm saying in the event
that a national divorce happens
it doesn't have to be that Nevada files
a declaration of secession it can be
that Nevada just says guys we're not
we're losing water and the Biden
Administration has not responded to us
they've told us they're strapped and
they can't send law enforcement we're on
our own now and then you get State you
get Interstate conflict I'm wondering
from your perspectives Ashley the thing
I have issue I have with libertarianism
I feel like it doesn't jive with the
presidency because it's such an
authoritarian role like you're the
military commander you suppose that's
your main job is command the military so
like how would you handle the military
in in with Taiwan or if there wasn't you
said you wouldn't issue a draft you just
let people like be on their own yeah I
think if you're gonna join the military
you should always be on voluntary terms
we should never make anybody a war
fighter uh because we say they have to
be a Warfighter I think that goes away
against the whole entire identity of of
consent
um and so yes I'm against I'm definitely
against that uh listen I I don't know I
I know that since the Nixon ERA with the
Taiwan and China thing we've kind of had
this double fail say for like China
don't mess with Taiwan we may go to war
with you and then with Taiwan it was
kind of like listen Taiwan don't mess
with China we may not protect you and
it's worked since then
um but now obviously it's not and I
think it's it's such a weird thing
because we have
you know we have the government that's
saying Russia is not allowed to
um uh take a rogue Province from Ukraine
but on the other hand uh China's not
allowed to take I guess I'm mixing that
up they're they're not allowed to have
their Rogue province in in Taiwan right
and uh Ukraine is has to let there's uh
has to get theirs back or whatever you
know even though they're mostly ethnic
Russians living there and uh so I I just
I'm not gonna like go and play you know
Civil War around the country with our
military it's not worked out for us it's
not worked out in the Middle East
um that for decades and decades and
decades I think it's just it's it's it's
bad I mean just to defend against an
invasion yeah and that's and I'm not I'm
not at all against National Defense I
think we we have a much better chance of
Defending against an invasion if we have
our troops at home because no you know
nobody's trying to come here and attack
us since since 1930s right I mean Pearl
Harbor 40s and it's and that's still
technically very very far away yeah
Hawaii is very far yeah it was a
military operation yeah it's far away
it's like when we're talking about
Taiwan Taiwan is 7 000 miles away from
here it's only nine what 90 miles from
China you know what I mean if we go and
have this this theater in over there by
Taiwan we're gonna lose an aircraft
carrier maybe what's going to happen
what's Joe Biden going to do if we lose
an aircraft carrier I mean it's gonna
get real ugly real quick it feels I
wanna so much like Ukraine like it's
just a it's another piece of land that's
right next to their country that we have
control of it's like dude what thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time